welcome everyone to the debut of the
Ingram angle we're gonna dive in today's
indictments and implications for the
Trump administration and of course our
exclusive interview with White House
chief of staff John Kelly shortly but
first the angle I want to start by
posing a basic question the one that
Sinatra asked in that old song what is
America to me it's a question that gets
lost in the constant infighting that
consumes us here in Washington Ronald
Reagan said that the American Dream is
not that every man must be level with
every other man the American Dream is
that every man must be free to become
whatever gods in God intends he should
become but over the past few decades the
government became an obstacle to people
realizing that dream
look politics is supposed to be a career
devoted to public service protecting our
life our liberty and the pursuit of
happiness but for too long it was
dominated by special interests big
business and of course the media elites
the politicians were supposed to be
helping you instead they help themselves
they were elected to run the government
not to run you over with it millions of
Americans voted for Trump because they
had had enough they were tired of being
bullied by politicians and the so-called
experts who gave us endless wars saddled
us with 20 trillion dollars in debt and
left us with a border more wide open
than Harvey Weinstein's robe they were
tired of the ruling by partisan elites
in Washington an immediate establishment
that didn't just cover them but covered
for them day to day one of most of you
worried about paying the bills sending
your kids to a decent school your health
care may be saving something for
retirement most of us I think want three
things prosperity safety liberty and
that includes preserving our history so
far despite the endless negative
reporting
we the people are doing pretty well
under Trump the economy is soaring
unemployment is down the trade deficit
is down Trump is renegotiating NAFTA and
other unfair and outdated trade deals
he's reformed the VA
he's appointed incredible judges to the
federal bench more coming this week and
of course justice coarsest to the
Supreme Court
he's enforcing the border novel concept
and deporting violent criminals who
doesn't want that so what are Trump's
opponents resisting again I'll tell you
what they're really resisting is losing
power the people took their power back
on election day and the establishment is
mad as hell what's facing I really don't
like the American people not not very
much at least or their forefathers
there's a self-loathing in the air do
you feel it forces hell-bent on erasing
our historical memory American monuments
works of art literature the remembrances
of men and women who imperfectly made
their mark on the American experiment
are being ripped from the classrooms and
the public square the memory and works
of Washington Jefferson General Lee heck
even Harper Lee are being sacrificed on
the high altar of political correctness
what kind of country are we leaving our
children we all future generations the
opportunity to understand the glories
and yes the sins of the people who made
these United States of America our
children have a right to be fully
informed a right to a complete record of
what went before and yes
the chance to ask themselves in time
what is America to me in George
Washington's farewell address written
with Alexander Hamilton he said of all
the dispositions and habits which lead
to political prosperity religion and
morality are indispensable supports in
vain would that man claim the tribute of
patriotism
who should labor to subvert these great
pillars of human
happiness these firmest props of the
duties of men and citizens what we
believe our love of God family and
country
these aren't trite relics of the past
but are at the very core of who we are
as Americans
this show is going to be about all of
this and certainly the political the
legal and the cultural battles of the
day but something more how all of that
affects your life and that of your
families I take all of this very
personally I'm doing this because I care
about what happens to this country to
our children and our children's children
now there'll be times when you disagree
with me and sometimes vehemently so and
I'm sure you're gonna let me know but
all I'll say is that I'm going to call
it as I see it as I've done for the past
20 years and I'm going to get answers
for you and I'm gonna hold the powerful
accountable and that includes you mr.
president and every night with you will
continue to answer this question what is
America to me to all of us